hallo leute waren und heute testen wir
ein harry potter café was mitten in hong
lin so liegt in südkorea das café 943
ist ein wirklich sehr beeindruckendes
gebäude was von kopf bis fuß an harry
potter erinnert und das liegt nicht
zuletzt an den wunderschönen kleinen
details die überall versteckt sind das
café ist aufgeteilt in mehreren etagen
im keller ist der wizard hat in der
ersten etage was in korea das
erdgeschoss ist findet man das café
beziehungsweise bekommt man dort das
essen und die getränke in der zweiten
etage ist dass rosat café in der dritten
etage findet man die große halle und die
vierte etage soll an den aufenthaltsraum
der schüler erinnern ich liebe einfach
diese mischung aus der britischen harry
potter welt und südkorea
eines morgens lag ich im bett und habe
nach cafés und shops in der nähe
gekommen findet dieses kaffees einfach
im harry potter thema ist es ist
natürlich nicht offiziell harry potter
das dürfen die er nicht verwenden wegen
rechtlichen gründen jetzt ist das 943
café das problem wir heute mal austesten
und durch kaufen so viel wie möglich und
zeigen einfach wie es da drin so
aussieht ich bin mal gespannt ich will
waren nicht drin glück kaum reine sich
mal die zauberstäbe wie bei oli wann das
steht hier 943 king's cross und zauber
büschel und wedelt der erste eindruck
des kaffees ist wirklich sehr schön denn
alles ist so schön detailreich dekoriert
man stellt sich an eine schlange und
dann bestellt man sich ein getränk
außerdem gibt es noch eine vitrine mit
kuchen man darf nur ins café de ein wenn
man sich in getränk gestellt sonst ist
es ja hier die wollen ja auch was
verkaufen und ich lese da hin das eine
mädchen plötzlich
sie ist sein erster eindruck
das ist ein krasses sie das gefühl
bekommen haben uns wirklich etwas von
merchandise zu benutzen will der asta
finale
rödingen world würde hier aber so ganz
die tür eintreten ja wirklich in diesem
samstagnachmittag
alle hart
auch nicht folgen die bestellung ist ein
brandzeichen limonade produktlinien denn
draußen bahnvertreter wir werden
herausfinden
[Musik]
euro
wir haben eine mutter liebe stellt und
ein user täglich
haben jetzt so ein bei bruder bekommt
bei uns bescheid könnte dennoch hätte
ich es aber ich hab schon diese platte
gesehen mit diesen tagen kommt ein
gewohnt keine kosten und mühen gescheut
oder ausgestopft und hier
[Musik]
zweitens auch noch mal das ich gesagt
café im dritten ist kann zu essen
es kommt folgt
und was sagen wie ich bin
wir müssen aufpassen
[Musik]
der erste eindruck vom keller ich hatte
das gefühl bei animal crossing zu sein
weil sie nicht wisst was ich meine bei
animal crossing kann man viel bauen aber
benutzen kann man am ende nur die tische
die wiederwahl bereit so darf ich wenn
sie nicht zufällig liegen ständig
miteinander zu tun sie sind jetzt hier
auch dem letzten klar sagen was hier und
hier kann man sich ja
legitim und vor einem leuchtenden aber
hält hat er seit weihnachten muss
willkommen im wiener café hier kann man
sich dann beträgen hinsetzen hier wird
aber nicht mehr ausgeschenkt
dann kam auch schon unsere getränke und
auch wenn sie nicht offiziell harry
potter sind erinnern sie doch sehr stark
daran und das macht wirklich spaß ok
mit liebe und auch machen wer sehr
hübsch alle hier ist auch so mit zucker
so ein papier oben drauf und ich weiß
aber nicht woraus besteht wir probieren
machen
[Musik]
das schmeckt
die kommission
mit der butter die erfahrung vielleicht
mit einem infekt
oder wie schmeckt eigentlich zum 90 es
ist am ende dass er die sonne sehr milch
im kaffee mit sehr viel wandel sirup und
unglaublich ist aber irgendwo eine ganz
miese gemacht
kraft ja sowieso ein café mit
kaffeegeschmack aber definitiv keine
bürgerwehr und jetzt kommt die sechste
schokolade das ist möglich dass alles
gut
wenn man revanche
das ist ein tabu chino
hose intoleranz gibt es auf der ganzen
welt
wenn ich jetzt so
denken
denn hin jahren zwei pott kaffee was man
essen und trinken und schön in überherrn
batterien dass unsere lieblings stellen
und nachdem timo sein kamera akku
gewechselt hat konnten wir auch etwas zu
essen ausprobieren und wie das lief seht
selbst
[Musik]
dipl -ing
mit alkohol treibt worden rap ist
beginnen wir zu unserem nächsten gang
wir probieren natürlich noch weitere
getränke aus wie zb butter wir mit
alkohol und zu habe ich mir das
vorgestellt meine leute so schöne
schaumkrone und hoffen sich ein leckeres
bier
fantastisch
10.15 und so will man wieder wir haben
ich glaube es immer wieder seine doch
probieren macht plan oben auf ein bier
schmeckt
ja ich weiß dass gemeinsam mit renault
und die richtig magische mango limonade
die kaufen
und jetzt stelle ich euch mal die klasse
fahren die man hier höher
48.000 worden was umgerechnet ungefähr
35 euro sind was ich mit wenig ist aber
man bekommt dafür eine riesenfete
türkei lag also eine tut heute das sieht
auch die entwickler markt dann gibt es
dazu noch kroketten und pommes mit einer
salsa obendrauf harry thomas mexiko
pater
claudius
mitunter saison traf und kurz los ist
wilde kombinationen
ich bin ehrlich
gespannt die polizei
habe warum ich glaube da nicht viel
falsch machen oder haben die schmecken
nicht so ganz gut da ist so eine
gewitzte in der tomatensoße flügeln das
kann man nicht viel falsch machen
und wie
also auf dem bild so ein bisschen größer
aussehen wird von den größen so ein
bisschen für zwei bis drei personen
die leckeren kaffee schmeckt so das
wichtigste kommt
dass man hat schon gekommen
[Musik]
ich war als kind häufig dass fahrer
machen wenn man unsere bürger dann die
keule reinbold
natürlich muss man menschen auf 20
minuten später also jetzt wo wir ein
bisschen was davon gegessen haben
kann man schon festhalten das ist
eigentlich schon mit dass die klubs
dessen ist was wir jemals in unserem
leben
[Musik]
ich kann sie erstens nicht erst
plötzlich krieg und geräuchertem fleisch
und fisch drehen und falls sie jetzt
denkt aber warum gestellt was bereichert
das was du nicht essen kannst das war
nicht ausgeschildert also es ist ein
terminal ich dachte die ganze zeit eine
million häuser das schmeckt nicht mal
nachts haben es schmeckt nach
richtiger schritt in die kasseler in
ganz schlecht ja ein ganz schlechter
kasseler timo hat sich ein bisschen
versucht dadurch zu kämpfen es ist von
der qualität sehr schlecht und in der
mitte kalt das heißt es wird halt
aufgewärmt was ja nicht schlimm ist wenn
man zeit durch werben würde na ja und
die kommen sind halt kalt und überhaupt
nicht kann oder frittiert dass sie sind
sehr weich das ist brot schmeckt komisch
haben wir einen verletzten aber die
anderen dass
der gewinner und die nation war auch gut
aber halt nicht gerade einfach doppelt
weh weil einerseits wenn man sich erst
eingestellt möchte man es natürlich auch
essen und nicht angeknabbert wieder
zurückgeben und der preis ist ein
wirklich so viel gewesen dass es
eigentlich gar nicht zu rechtfertigen
ist warum man da so eine mindere
qualität serviert ich meine denke dass
wir von diesem café oder von diesem
restaurant café ist ja ganz cool und sie
haben sich auch wirklich mühe gegeben
ich mein man hat hier wirklich das
gefühl bei harry potter in der welt zu
sein ohne dass ihre lizenzen brauchen
und dann schreiter zeit so beim essen
das finde ich schade gerade weil man da
so viel geld ausgibt und die im namen
seiner badekappe viel zeit sparen aber
die kostet halt auch so um die acht euro
da war wo man ja auch einige frauen wir
es auch okay
ich habe trinke ich mir jetzt ein ich
glaube dass viele von euch hier
überhaupt hinkommen werden brauche ich
nicht mal nicht zu empfehlen aber
heute ist unser letzter tag hier und ich
dachte ich kann hier mal
einen schönen abschluss feiern aber
kannst du nicht mal für höflich zu
reagieren die sollen sagen dass code und
middle
east like shit ende wird es kaum und
machte dann auch klar wird man schon
noch mal geben können aber dafür wird
auch sich ebenso wie angefressen ist
angetreten das außen landen aber wir
gucken wollten gab es überall in der
mitte so kalt aber weißt was ich nämlich
auf dem ich habe auch es gibt das eine
ablage
ob ich schon so ein paar kräuter
ein bisschen zu viel essen stehen sehen
was am abend gefasst nehme der raumkunst
leute etwas für teuer geld und dann
leben sie so heimann kosten zurück
glauben weil alle das hier machen
umgestellt was ist schmeckt übrigens
ebenso wieder zurück und sie denken
bestimmt dass das irgendwie englische
küche oder so ist sehr deprimierend
leiter wir sehen zur im nächsten video
wieder ich mache jetzt erst nach diesem
schock erholen